نحن الان في مدينه كهرمان مرعش نقف عند
هذا المبنى الذي يتالف من تسع طوابق انهار
بالكامل فراق الانقاذ تقول بان هناك خمس
اشخاص عالقين في سياره في موقف السيارات
اسفل هذه الانقاذ احد الاشخاص قال بانه
تلقى الرساله من الاشخاص العالقين اسفل
هذه الانقاض وبالتالي تقوم فلك الانقاذ في
محاوله الوصول الى هؤلاء
باستخدام الكلاب المدربه وايضا باستخدام
اجهزه اجهزه استشعار لا زالت عمليات البحث
متواصله في هذه الاثناء احد يعني عناصر
الانقاذ جاء وحذرنا من هذا المبنى الذي
تشاهدونه الان وتشاهدون التصدعات هو مبنى
للسقوط وقال بان هناك اصوات حسب المختصين
تصدر من هذا المبنى والمخاوف تتزايد من
هزات ارتداديه ربما تضرب وهناك العديد من
الهزات الارداديه السلطات تقول بان اكثر
من 800 هزار ارتدا منذ يوم الزلزال وحتى
اليوم وبالتالي هذا يشكل قلق كبير وخوف
كبير لدى السلطات التركيه وعمليات الانقاذ
على ايه حال هذا جزء من مشهد صغير كما
تشاهدونه في جميع المدن التي ضربها
الزلزال وما زالت عمليات الانقاذ مستمره
وهم يسارع او يسابقون الزمن
لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه خصوصا ان العالقين
بقيوا لساعات طويله وطويله جدا
كهرمان مرعش